في ضواحي ادي سببه تتحرك افريقيا مصغره
داخل هذا المعمل على بساطته
انهم يخطون معالم احذيه
سيصنعونها في قاره تخط بدورها طريقها
هؤلاء العاملات جزء من عدد اكبر فهناك من
يعملن من منازلهن تشتبك خيوط امالهم
لصناعه وضع
افضلني لرفع التحدي طلبت مع اخي في هذا
المعمل لصناعه الاحذيه واقترضنا المال من
الاهل واجهنا صعوبات وتمكنا من توسيع
المعمل كما دربنا ووظفنا فتيات بدانا
توزيع بضاعتنا محليا ووصلت حتى اليابان
نحو خمسه وخمسين في المئه من النساء وفق
البنك الدولي يشاركنا في النشاط الاقتصادي
للقاره
اطلب من قاده افريقيا تمكين المراه
الافريقيه ومنحها فرصا اكبر لتغيير
المجتمع للافضل وفرصا للتسطير والاستيراد
بطرق اسهل عبر التجاره الحره
صاحبه معمل الاحذيه نموذج لامراه افريقيه
قاومت الفقر صمدت واختارت ان تبادر هي
صوره لافريقيا الحالمه بوجه جديد تبحث عن
اجابات وحلول لمشاكلها على بعد بضع
كيلومترات من مقر الاتحاد الافريقي حيث
تلتئم قمه جديده للاتحاد في ظل تحديات
كبيره
تعددت ملفات القمه بين اهانه التكامل
الاقتصادي وملفات النزاعات والحروب
وابرزها مبادره اسكات البنادق مرورا بجرد
عشر سنوات من العمل على اجنده 63 لتنميه
القاره قمه هذه المره تاتي في ظل حاله
تدافع وتنافس دولي رئيس المفوضيه
الافريقيه اتهم شركاء افريقيا الماليين
بفرض شروط قاسيه لتمويل التنميه فيها
للاسف في مواجهه الوعود الجذابه وعدم
الوفاء بالتمويل من شركائنا تجد الدول
الاعضاء نفسها مضطره لتحمل الديون في ظروف
شديده القسوه كما يتضح من مفاوضاتها مع
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه لابد ان تحسم
دولنا بحزم خياراتها الاقتصاديه
والانمائيه في اهتمام غير مسبوق عجه اروقه
مقر الاتحاد الافريقي بوفود غربيه اوروبيه
امريكيه روسيه صينيه وغيرها انا اعتقد انه
يجب ان يسمى هذا الحضور الدولي بانه انزال
دبلوم
اسي لعرض القاره الافريقيه ولانها للاسف
تحولت الى ساحه صراع دولي تصفى فيها
الحسابات بشعار تسريع تنفيذ منطقه التجاره
الحره الافريقيه اراد الافارقه ان يفتحوا
صفحه جديده وفي حال نجاحها سيعني ذلك سوقا
تجاريه واعده بنحو تريليونين وخمسمائه
مليار دولار عبد القادر عراضه الجزيره هذه
سببه